there was another Super Bowl ad that  everyone's talking about that featured  mr. clean sort of did you see this one  as the object of sexual desire yeah  check it out  [Music]  yeah I was really uh you know a lot of  people were talking about that because  you think about it's a weird choice to  sexualize a brand mascot that way mr.  clean has never been that way they they  really sexualized the brand mascot but  it still wasn't nearly as bad as this  other ad that aired later in the night  this one got to me Lady Bird  well it's your recipe so good my syrup  is made with real butter for a richer  thicker taste that's my secret thank you  so would you like to stick your dick  inside the only leading syrup brand made  with real butter also  [Applause]  [Laughter]  why did he have to leave the kitchen  there alone I have my theories  [Laughter]  you